[Music]
adam's gonna start us off in atlanta
georgia hi adam welcome to the ramsay
show
uh hi dave and rachel how are you both
doing today
great man what's up
so my question is whether i should buy
or rent um so a little background i'm
currently serving in the army
getting ready to move duty stations here
this summer
my next assignment will be for about
three years and i'm just wondering what
is going to set me up
in the best position to buy a rent
so great great question adam number one
thanks for
your service we appreciate that
everyone that serves we we greatly honor
you and appreciate you
and when it comes to
um
buying a home and staying in something
long term
kind of the rule of thumb that we always
use is around five years so if you're
gonna be somewhere five years and
permanently stay there then investing
into a home
is a great option um but we've talked to
a lot of military folks out there that
you know that you guys in essence of
what you do that you you are moving
constantly and sometimes it's it's more
of a headache to own something and try
to keep that going versus just renting
because oftentimes it's short term like
you said just three years
so usually the role of thumb there is is
if you're there five years or longer
that's what i would recommend buying
here's the two sides of the equation
adam that you and you can run the
equation for yourself all right
what happens too many times is guys in
the military gals in the military think
oh owning a home is always smart
everybody should own a home you ought to
buy a house shout out by a house and
they buy a house in a military community
where there's constant turnover and it's
very difficult to sell a house because
there's always a bunch of houses for
sale
also they don't always go up in value as
much because there's always a bunch of
houses for sale and then they end up oh
well i'll just rent it and you look up
at the end of your career and you got
seven rental properties in seven
different cities that were former
residences that you became a landlord by
default well that we don't want you to
do and you don't want to do that okay
now the times that you can buy is what
rachel's saying when you reach a point
in your career or
you uh take the type of a position in
your career where you're going to be
there a little longer it's going to make
sense
even if you're there only three years
there's a few times it might work and
here's how you can actually do the math
to make the decision okay
you can contact one of our elps in the
area one of our real estate elps in the
area and you're looking for two things
in that market
and uh i would go back a couple of years
um i wouldn't i wouldn't count
this last 12 months because they're
weird
in the real estate market but other than
the last 12 months i would say what is
the average appreciation rate within
five or 10 miles of the area i'm looking
at
okay and if the average appreciation
rate is three percent and you're there
three years you're going to lose money
when you resell you understand
okay but if the average appreciation
rate not counting whacked out 21 okay or
or the end of 20 if the average
appreciation rate is 7 to 10 what's
going to go up 30 percent
while you're there
and you know you could probably make
money agreed
right but you need to be able to resell
it and that's the second statistic
you're looking for which is dom
days on the market what's the average
days on the market on homes within a 10
mile radius of where i am looking if the
average days on the market is 270 that's
nine freaking months you're stuck in
this house
you can't give it away
you don't buy there you follow me
but if the average days on the market
within a 10 mile radius is three days
or 21 days or something like that that's
a pretty hot market oh by the way you're
going to see these numbers correlate
if you're seeing good uh good increases
in value you're going to see short days
on the market
you're going to see them together if you
see long days on the market you're going
to see lower increases in value and it
literally depends on the area
i mean if you're navy and you get
stationed in san diego you probably roll
in and out of that baby and make some
money yeah but if you're in the
the plains of kansas and there's no one
within a 20-mile radius except military
people
you're not going to get out of that one
you know that's not going to be a
long-term investment for you unless
you're there long term so that's the way
you can run the numbers on it and tell
but most of the time i'd say 90 of the
time when you do all that you're going
to discover if i'm here three years it
doesn't make sense well and even that i
mean
whether it's you know military or we
even talk to to young couples that you
know they just newlyweds that get
married they want a house but just the
factor of owning a home and everything
that it takes to keep up with that
there's just a level of that
responsibility you always have to filter
through when you own a home because it's
it's all yours the more crap you you
know the more the more crap you own the
more repairmen you have to know 100
there so sometimes it's you know and i
think within the military i know
different positions take you know
different levels of stress for sure but
especially if you're in
a stressed
filled
you know role in the military there's a
part of you that's like there's a yeah
just don't worry yeah it's something you
don't want to worry about when you're
renting
we'll call the landlord no i don't know
there's something i like about that yeah
call the landlord and go hey your house
is broke come fix it come fix it yeah
and then it gets fixed then you're done